also developing this morning shots fired
near the Las Vegas Strip this happened
outside the Bellagio as hundreds of
people are trying to enjoy their Sunday
night Bianca Holman is live on the Las
Vegas Strip with the details on this
Bianca good morning good morning John
well thankfully nobody was hurt but
definitely scary moments last night here
on the Las Vegas Boulevard and it
happened around 11:00 p.m. matter of
fact one of the shows here at the
Bellagio the water show had just ended
when shots rang out
I found like oh I like gunshots
and so that video is from Brett Poli
posted to Twitter you hear several
gunshots and soon's the tourists panic
and run other video posted to social
media shows a huge police presence as
officers rushed to the scene Metro
Police tell us they did not they they
actually recovered shell casings but
that no one was hit thankfully and Las
Vegas Boulevard was closed for well over
an hour during the investigation
detectives are working with the Bellagio
security to see if there was a video of
the gunman and last checked police have
not made any arrests just yet and
anytime something like this happens on
the strip metro takes it very very
seriously so as they continue to
investigate and keep us up-to-date
updated we will do the same reporting
live from Las Vegas Boulevard and
flamingo Bianca Holman 8 news now